Southern Hills Hospital is giving us a
look at how their surgical robots are
taking over the medical field today CCSD
students got a hands-on experience with
the robot to help them become more
comfortable with hospitals 8 news now
reporter Victoria Saha has details from
today's event
I'm here at Southern Hills Hospital
the hospital good thank you so much for
being here of course you got such a
crowd so tell us what this event is so
we partnered with the Las Vegas science
is everywhere Festival it's a festival
going on throughout the week what we're
doing here is showing how robots are
saving lives so I feel like a lot of
people don't really know that robots are
involved in a lot of surgeries that we
have here at the hospital so it's really
cool kids get to come and play with the
robots see them see how they work the
robots doing the surgeries
um that's a pretty unique thought right
how is that being received so I want to
clarify the robots aren't technically
doing the surgeries right we still have
surgeons that are in the operating room
they are the ones using the robots they
can do some things that surgeons can't
so the doctors how do they get to decide
that okay this might be a surgery for a
robot so that's going to be completely
up to the surgeon and basically if they
are interested in doing you know using
robots for their surgery that's going to
be some extra training but it's Cutting
Edge technology so most surgeons are on
board they want to be offering the best
to their patients we at Southern Hills
want to be offering the best to our
patients so surgeons can decide
basically what their specialty is and if
they're going to use robots
now those robots cost more than a
million dollars they're used for the
simplest surgeries all the way to more
advanced procedures kids attending
today's event were able to pretend to do
surgery on teddy bears